a compadre of mine for a very long time
please to call this man a friend he is
two-time Super Bowl champion Super Bowl
MVP Pro Football Hall of Famer Terrell
Davis how are you sir like that intro
rich that was nice eight six and four
okay pause for a second because I'm a
five-year-old he's not quite six so I
just call him you just upgraded six next
month okay six right
do you consider Phillip Lindsey your
child yes yeah I am a proud papa you are
that's the way I feel it's funny you
wanted a minute the entire year I feel
so we've been kicking ourselves all year
long why because you came on the show
late summer did I asked you okay
this kid Phillip Lindsey he's under EFT
and he asked for your number thirty and
you said okay yeah and that bothered you
a little bit but don't even bother me I
want to excuse me it didn't bother me I
always look out for your best
I was like what's up with that right and
you basically said kids not only cool
but he is old-school and he's really
good otherwise I wouldn't have given it
to him and we should have gone on the
waiver wire on our fashion month like oh
and neither of us did like you dropped
that little Easter egg
listen to what I'm saying I know he's
eight notes will not say something I
hell he was dynamite yeah he was good
I mean sensational season I can't tell
you I saw that I didn't see Provo I
didn't see him a thousand yard rusher
but I thought he could be really good
and he's listening that offense but he I
think he surpassed everybody's
expectation and now he is the man he is
the guy is it's no it's no longer funny
to see number 30 out there and think why
is he wearing that number no I buy the
way it's good that you don't feel our
still me I still can't get used to it he
didn't know what he looked he just he
looks different than I do if he looked
like me we had the same like features
and he wore third ever you lose are but
he's lazy he's totally different he's
smaller kind of a scatback
different different skill sets yeah yeah
I guess there's like college right you
leave college
the next player comes in he wears your
jersey number so that's the way I kind
of see it okay who wears your jersey
number for Georgina who is that 33 I
don't know does anybody wear this is it
for anybody out there always watching
NFL Network watching on NFL Network we
worked used to work with this remember
that time where meet was me you and
Emmitt Smith on the air talking about
talking about the Atlanta Falcons I do
and he was talking about Dunn who I saw
earlier today and Duquette he goes and
there's another guy who's at 33 and we
were like and we looked no you looked at
me then I turn the researcher like I
don't know look on TV when somebody says
nobody knows who he is and what's
supposed to be ex-works
now here we are right 15 years later
wondering who's 33 in donald mcintyre
well there you go
what do you think this week is like for
Gurley for tickets a lot of requests you
know he's played at the University of
Georgia obviously this is home for him
and it's a lot you know it's a lot to
manage and you have to have a good team
around to people who understand that
you're not here to to party you're not
here to have a good time you're here to
take care of business and they can't be
offended by it that you can't carve out
time to see them if you have people in
your corner who are like that then
they'll understand he should be okay but
you have you have people who take
offense to it that you came in town a
big game like this and you didn't put
them sort of on a pedestal to say hey
let me spend time with you and singling
them out and carve you know time that
you really don't have for them so my
Super Bowl first one was in San Diego
I'm from San Diego so I know exactly
what that feels like yes and it was
rough I can tell you rich because when I
got there my high school decide to
retire my jersey number and I was like
oh how convenient
I don't remember being that good in high
school yyy-you retiring my jersey number
but it was to get you know get the fans
there get the TV cameras there and sort
of shed light on my high school which I
was cool with and I did all that on you
know Monday Tuesday and Wednesday and
then it started to back things down on
Thursday and then Friday about time I
got to Friday I was trying to get back
into the regular routine which is we're
just tough to do and especially when
you're on the road somewhere it's just
hard to do now I'm gonna put you a
little bit on the spot go for using your
school pride yes the leaping off point
here Terrell Davis Super Bowl xxxii MVP
correct Super Bowl 40 MV P your
backfield made at Georgia Hines Ward yes
okay yeah who do you think has the best
shot potentially of joining you and
Hines in the Georgia Bulldog running
back Super Bowl MVP award possibility
one Gurley or Sony Mejia
which is part of our poll question today
is to in a way who is okay and VP but
I'm just I'm just making it a Georgia
Bulldog Lester that's fair that's fair
and I'm I'm going with Todd Gurley and
here's why if Sony has a good game then
I think Tom Brady is probably gonna have
something that he's gonna falter it he's
gonna be with James White had that
sensational game in Super Bowl yeah Tom
Brady had a spectacular and I just feel
like Tom will do enough on the stage
like this we know tom is going to come
he's gonna deliver and so that's gonna
be hard to take that honor from Tom
Brady
if the Rams play well I think a lot of
that would be because Todd Gurley was
Todd Gurley that we saw all year long
and we'll see this guy who you know was
there probably MVP halfway through the
season and then sort of tailed off at
the end of the season but yeah I'll say
Todd Gurley has a greater chance of
doing it now that said Sony Michele
playing the Rose Bowl yeah playing in
the national championship game in this
building then play in the building again
for the Super Bowl that is an
unbelievable trifecta for a calendar
year of football
essentially for for Sonia Michelle yeah
it is and to your point you know wasps
plan
in San Diego we would play the Chargers
you know twice a year once in San Diego
one in Denver and then the same year we
end up planning a Super Bowl so I was
able to go back to my my city twice
right in that particular year and this
is you know again you're trying to keep
it in perspective because it's such a
special moment and you know you're
playing it from your your friends your
friends family everybody and this you
just have have to handle the situation
the right way cuz they can get out of
out of control right you know if you
don't so yeah so Sony's doing great this
year we got Nick Chubb to who's not in
the system right he was terrific
he was terrific for the Cleveland Brown
when they handed him the reins he just
took it ran with it you know we do it I
dunno how you do it all Davis here on
the Richardson show Saturday night looks
like we're gonna hear Pat Poland's name
it lived to join you in Elway among
others in the Pro Football Hall of Fame
what will that mean to you alone we're
next to the trophy that was once upon a
time the hosted by Pat Bowlen for John
etc it would mean a lot great deal and
you know Pat's not doing well right now
but I just go back to when I first got
to Denver and I met Pat and I just
remember thinking that I've not met an
owner before so I don't know what owners
typically how to deal with their players
but it didn't feel like a typical owner
player relationship he was pretty
personal always ask questions about your
family anything I've ever needed you
know Pat was there and he never wanted
to take credit for anything he always
wanted to be in the background and let
things happen but he just had a kind
heart and he was he was a winner he
wanted to do everything so that we can
win you know so we had at the time we
had one of the biggest I believe
payrolls on our our coaching staff
because every player had an idea about
how they can improve the team and we'd
go to Mike and Mike said well I gotta go
to the man upstairs and the man said hey
if it's gonna make us better do it and
so we had all kinds of biomechanics all
kind of people helping us with all all
these different things and it worked and
I remember so we had and this is a
simple thing but on a roll no roommates
now people say you know that's not a big
deal but it is to me because I prepare
different than somebody else so
we didn't have roommates on the road
we'd have simple things like having free
movies in your room - free movies in
your room you can watch him but I mean
silly but it sounds like but that's that
there's the small gestures that he did
to make you feel like he wanted to run a
first-class organization and he wanted
to treat you in that manner and in
response that you would you know
obviously play for him and and he got
those results but bigger than that when
I tore my ACL in 1999 came out of the
surgery the first phone call I got was
from Pat Bowlen and so we would just
talk about everything you know I would
ask him advice on finances advice on
just experience in his life and he was
always there for me so this is gonna be
a special time and I know he's going in
so I'm looking forward to it is it's
pretty neat and you know there's some
interesting stories you were telling and
to any other host you would not have to
tell the story I'm about to ask you
because I've know you I've known you for
very long
yes you don't kind of know where I'm
going on this one just yet but when you
said it's important to have your own
room on the road because we prepare
differently for games where's this going
man what did you take what did you
always take before a game I would take a
bath at night not just did you have did
you have your road Robert I didn't have
a rubber duckie no I did not have the
rocket I had - that was a superstition
that was it I had that plus I had to
have M&Ms plain M&Ms on vanilla ice
cream the same night that was it the
combination and he sit in my bathtub and
I just relax with my ice cream and M&Ms
and dominate that was it okay that's all
in which will be a very nice moment yeah
and Pat was very integral to the NFL
Network is that he was always around and
he was the first owner to visit he was
always around whenever we were when we
were doing something special
the Super Bowl or something like that
the first ever Thursday night football
game on the NFL Network was a
Thanksgiving night game in Kansas City
with the Broncos and he was there
obviously with the team and that was the
night where Adam Schefter came up with
the scoop that no matter whether the
Broncos were gonna win that night Jake
Plummer was gonna be benched in favor of
Jay Cutler and not even Ramona and knew
it he came to our green parking lot look
he's like where's Adam Schefter like he
was really cool about because he never
got up so I've never seen that may exist
that he was always cool as a cucumber a
used you song always hope everyone was
like where is out of schechter Pat
Bowlen with mr. polar wants to see him
you know he put that out I know and also
just for fancy or may not know and I'm
about to break a little bit of news to
you about my 40-yard dash run you might
not have heard but you weren't what you
read it again well I'm going to at the
combine as you know right the reason why
I bring this up is when I run at the
combine in my suit every year it was
born out of a fit of boredom waiting to
shoot a segment for the NFL Total Access
program at the 2005 combine with me
sitting next to you yes indeed I
remember that in the in this advance yep
we were waiting yep I turned to you and
I said how fast you think I can run the
40-yard dash yeah which you then we got
suits Ornan ties and he wants to run a
40-yard dash you look at rich you didn't
like it so I did I give you a time by
the way that I did I'll say what no what
you would what actually happened is I
cursed you yes
first you like a curse you in the name
that I think word I cannot say into this
microphone in front of such nice people
as well in the studio audience and then
I went down and ran it had unbeknownst
to me they were shooting it filming it
and they surprised me later on it is now
morphed into as you know a charitable
venture yeah I love it man which is for
st. Jude Children's Research Hospital
and to kick off run rich Rome we've
never done it before the Superbowl yet
but we're gonna do it on Saturday for
Sunday's pregame show as a matter of
fact I'm running against Usain Bolt
[Laughter]
we're going to shoot it on Saturday okay
and show it on Sunday and I hope you'll
be on the set for that since you helped
launch this darn I mean the logo of the
show I mean who knew that I'd have a
show at that time I am proud of the logo
of this program with you to see you have
your own show I'm so proud of written
and what it's becoming me this is a
brand it's nice your icon now I'm trying
well I can't even go in and show after
kind of I got a I got a beg my I gotta
call up and get my show are you saying
I'm like the Cam Newton I'm an
entertainer and an icon is out you're
saying um Newton of our profession you
that you're completely so what do you
think what do you think my odds are
against you seeing Pope will I come will
I come hold on it is he giving you a
head start
no no but he also is we all know he's
used to running longer distances and
coming out of blocks I don't come out of
blocks I don't come out of blocks I come
out of a stance he's gonna have to get
the stance with no blocks so to him or
you okay so do you think do you think
I'll come within even 20 yards that he
finished yet to pass the I think you can
get 20 long fastest man on earth I know
sudha mad so he runs a 40 and what I
have been told three point and three and
change yes Wow like the high threes and
I run I run high five high five high
five
yeah high five really high yeah but you
about a six and he runs three and change
so yeah that's more than half what if he
runs backwards I don't want to get hurt
okay this is not a sideshow this is not
a circus re this is not a circus trying
to give you the best chance here me
versus Usain Bolt may sound circus like
but it's not what do you think Willie's
getting is the 20 I think you will give
you the
I'm encouraged by it does not sound like
you I'm not saying it with a lot of
optimism but I think you can do it okay
before we go you are wearing do not deny
shirt you've got a FY is defined what is
it and rich let me say after I thought I
was you know retired from football I've
had years of chronic pain and knee
swelling and and joint issues and it
just wasn't a really good time for me
and I've struggled with that throughout
the years on top of that I had migraines
as you would know yesterday for my
entire life and I've been finding trying
to find an all-natural solution and over
the last couple of years I discovered
CBD and it's really changed my life it's
transformed my life in a way that I
never thought it could do it and so the
fire is is my brand that we have CBD
products and we have our drink that's
coming out that really transforms lives
and you don't have to be an athlete as a
performance strength but you don't have
to be an athlete for it to before you
get the benefit and kind of what I'm
hoping I'm excited about is the way I
feel now trying to help other people who
have felt the way that I felt for many
years be able to have a sense of relief
and be able to get off medicine like I'm
not only anymore meds anymore that's
great for my migraines and stuff so I'm
I'm here and I and I'm having a great
time and just feeling really good and
excited about the future in the brand
and so uh that's what we are doing
website or something we had a website
Scott drink two five calm and go there
will be launching we have three flavors
we'll be launching in the spring and
then we also have our our tensors with
the CBD of that you can just take that
so if you say you don't have to be an
athlete to enjoy or feel the effects of
the benefits can I have some before my
run against Usain Bolt well
unfortunately don't have any right now
oh come on hey we work the long and hard
in the lab to perfect this and rich and
we'll get it be patient all right
there's a during in and after them so
yes I'll get you somehow make sure you
the next year though okay for next year
yes I'll be feel make sure that we give
it to you all year long so that let me
get to the
point your training and everything you
want to do is is gonna be right there
rich all right so uh so I'll be Terrell
Davis is lab rat next year fantastic TD
good to see you man
hey good you are the man always I look
forward I'll see it the only for game
day morning I'll see you this weekend
you can check out again
NFL gameday morning but you're also
gonna be are you gonna be on a no fly
game b-prime as well I am NOT they're
actually sending me back to LA you are
on Sunday you're the fort holder yeah
but like we have uh think we're doing
aftermath on Monday okay great yeah good
to see a TD tag you Sorrell underscore
Davis making you hat by the way to be
yeah you gotta wear this okay put it on
right here I'll rock the Hat you got a
rock the head okay when we come back Bob
craft is spoken about Tom Brady's future
I don't know if it involves this you
look good thank you you're absolutely
I'm coming for you
[Applause]
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience